um  also probably there is no knight c5  because suddenly g4 and  how to  how to protect here i mean we can  protect technically by by exchanging  queens but that's not what we want  check out the movie plays he lashes out  does duda he plays a very wild move here  um you know in that position where he's  trying to force an attack not always  easy to do so but  he's played um he's played at an f5  launch  in the position so  we're we're just uh adjust the board to  the back yeah as it was very easy  it's very easy to do that in in in the  software to make it bigger i'm sure i'm  sure our producer can  hopefully capture that easy enough  yeah we'll see all right get that back  right  you played f5 you see this  yeah f5 was such a bold move movie i  mean you desperately want to stop chief